.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ein Lauf, ein Gang
in etwas Unbekanntes.
Das hatten wir lange nicht mehr.
Grüezi, wir sind Manu ...
... und Jonny
vom Cabaretduo DivertiMento.
Seit 14 Jahren sind wir als Komiker
zusammen und haben viel erlebt.
Aber so etwas? Nein!
- Mir ist der Humor vergangen.
Wir waren in Schottland wandern,
auf dem West Highland Way.
Und zwar nicht nur zum Spass.
Das Ziel der Reise ist,
dass wir uns wieder näherkommen,
dass diese Freundschaft
wieder menschlicher wird
und weniger beruflich.
Drei Wochen, 150 km,
draussen bei Wind und Wetter.
Es ist auf jeden Fall härter,
als wir dachten.
* Stöhnen *
Es war eine anstrengende,
aber auch schöne Zeit.
Klar ausserhalb unserer Komfortzone.
Und genau das hat dieses Abenteuer
so einzigartig gemacht.
Das ist
"SRF bi de Lüt - Durch dick ...
... und dünn."
* Schiffshorn *
Im Hafen von Amsterdam
fing das Abenteuer an,
jedenfalls für mich.
Mein Bühnenpartner und Freund Jonny
war im Flugzeug
unterwegs nach Schottland.
Dort wollten wir gemeinsam wandern
und wieder mal Zeit für uns haben.
Das klingt ein bisschen
wie ein altes Ehepaar.
Da bleibt man hängen.
Ja, klein, aber fein!
Durch diese extrem intensiven Touren
und nahtlos Programme schreiben,
Shows schreiben,
ist daraus ein wenig
eine Berufsfreundschaft geworden.
Ich vermisse es manchmal etwas.
Ich habe unterdessen Familie,
bin absorbierter als früher.
Wir sind älter geworden.
Unser Leben hat sich verändert.
Im Beruf war brutal viel los.
So ist ein gewisser Druck,
Leistungsdruck aufgekommen.
Und die Lockerheit,
die Unbefangenheit in unserer
Freundschaft hat darunter gelitten.
Hoch über den Wolken sitze ich mit
den gleichen Gedanken im Flugzeug.
Ich bin froh, sitze ich nicht
dort unten im Nebel auf der Fähre.
Wir haben rausgefunden,
dass wir das letzte Mal
vor viereinhalb Jahren
gemeinsam privat unterwegs waren -
bevor Manu Papa wurde.
Ich freue mich darauf, neben der
Bühne Zeit mit Manu zu verbringen,
aber ich selbst wäre nie
nach Schottland wandern gegangen.
Ich wollte
schon immer mal nach Schottland.
Die Landschaft ist wunderschön.
Ich bin ein Naturfreak.
Idiot! Manu ist ein Idiot!
Ich wollte durch Italien.
Ich spreche die Sprache,
in Italien wären es jetzt 24 °C.
Es wird eine borstige Angelegenheit,
es wird eine bissige
und bisige Angelegenheit.
Ich habe Respekt
und etwas Schiss davor.
Richtig, Herr Burkart, richtig!
* "I'm Gonna Be (500 miles)"
von The Proclaimers *
Dauerregen -
das ist die Wetterprognose!
Dank Flugzeug war ich schon
einen Tag vor Manu in Glasgow
und konnte mich
ans schottische Klima gewöhnen.
Der Himmel ist blau,
aber gefühlt sind es -4 °C.
Ja, auf der Fähre
war es auch nicht wärmer.
Drei Wochen unterwegs,
ich habe ein Paar Hosen dabei.
Seit 30 Min. bin ich in Glasgow,
ich habe Flecken auf der Hose.
Ich falle um mit diesem Rucksack.
Ich weiss nicht mal,
woher die Flecken sind.
Es sieht blöd aus. So doof.
Jetzt laufe ich drei Wochen
so durch die Highlands.
Fischer, du hast ja Probleme!
Am nächsten Morgen
war bei mir Land in Sicht.
Nach dieser Nacht auf hoher See
bin ich nicht mehr so grosser Fan
einer Anreise mit Fähre.
Ich habe scheisse gepennt.
Wir sind etwa 15 Std. von Amster-
dam nach Newcastle hoch gefahren.
Newcastle, und von dort
gehen wir mit dem Auto weiter
etwa 2 1/2 Std. nach Glasgow
bzw. nach Milngavie,
wo unser Weg beginnt
und ich Jonny treffe.
Endlich! Es ist öde, alleine
in diesem Kabäuschen zu reisen. Bäh!
Und so bin ich ein paar Stunden
später in Milngavie angekommen,
einem Vorort von Glasgow.
Hier beginnt er,
der West Highland Way.
Das ist ...
... der Startstein.
Hier geht es los. Hey ho, let's go!
Nach einer wunderschönen Nacht
im Hotel im Zentrum Glasgows
bin ich auch bereit.
Es soll losgehen!
Das ist schön, so habe ich mir die-
sen West Highland Way vorgestellt.
Es ist erstaunlich trocken.
* "I'm gonna be (500 miles)"
von The Proclaimers *
* Kichern *
Er lacht sich kaputt.
Er kommt vom Bahnhof,
er hat sicher schon Blasen.
Sali!
Endlich!
- Hoi.
Das war ja was,
bis wir endlich hier waren.
Ist das alles? Sie sagten:
"Weisst du, hier geht es dann los!"
Puh, Scheisse!
Schön!
- Ich bin froh, dass es losgeht.
Das war eine zähe Anreise.
Etwas mussten wir vor dem Start
aber noch klären:
Wer ist Tageschef
und sagt, wo es langgeht?
Du bist heute Tageschef. Aber
was heisst das? Was darf der sagen?
Das Tempo vorgeben.
- Nein!
Nein, sonst bin ich am Arsch.
Nein, ich meine eher so:
Was essen wir?
Wo stellen wir das Zelt auf?
Wenn es in die Hose geht, ist
derjenige auch dafür verantwortlich.
Sehr schön! Machen wir es so.
Also ...
- Los geht's!
Endlich, wir kommen.
Ab die Post!
Bäh,
wie viele haben das schon gemacht?
Let's go!
- Adieu miteinander.
Enjoy!
- Thank you, thank you.
"Thank you, thank you" -
der hat doch nichts verstanden!
Unsere Reise
beginnt in Glasgow in Schottland.
Von hier führt der Wanderweg,
der West Highland Way,
150 km in den Norden, in die
Highlands, bis nach Fort William.
Wir waren
fast drei Wochen unterwegs.
* "These Boots Are Made For Walking"
von Nancy Sinatra *
Aber schon nach 30 m ...
Oh, bin ich froh!
- Endlich!
Ah, ist das gut!
Und Beinbruch!
- Ja, mit dem Rucksack.
Also, jetzt.
- Vamos!
Wo kann man die Hände waschen?
* "These Boots Are Made For Walking"
von Nancy Sinatra *
Das ist spannend.
"Anfang des 19. Jh. spielte der
dichte Wald vor den Toren Glasgows
eine gewisse Rolle ..."
Merkst du eigentlich, dass ich hier
im Dreck laufe und du im Trockenen?
Ich lese!
Ich bin Tageschef. Also bitte!
Ich laufe im Dreck.
- Jonny, bitte! Du musst dich fügen.
Endlich unterwegs. Für den ersten
Tag gab es eine Etappe von 8-10 km.
Aber das Ganze
mit Rucksack und Zelt.
Das hatte ich
zum letzten Mal in der RS.
Ich war letztes Jahr
mit meiner Tochter auf Schulreise
im Kemptner Tobel.
Und immer dabei: unsere Kameracrew.
Tja, wenn wir da
schon gewusst hätten,
dass wir sie am Abend
noch für anderes brauchen würden!
Hey, Manu, nichts verraten!
- Easy.
Excuse me,
is this the way to London?
Chef, müssen wir hier
links oder rechts?
(Mit schottischem Akzent)
We turn to the left.
* Sanfte Musik:
"Cargill" von King Creosote *
Wir können kaum glauben,
dass wir nur 4 km ausserhalb
der Grossstadt Glasgow sind.
(Lachend) Schafseckel!
Schafseckel!
* Lachen *
Ist aber schon geil.
- Megaschön.
Ich meine,
weil ich den Rucksack abgelegt habe.
Ist das ein Moor?
- Das ist Moor, wegen der Farbe.
Torfmull kommt von hier.
Habe ich gelesen.
- Klugscheisser Fischer.
Etwa so
haben wir uns das vorgestellt:
etwas wandern, gemütlich picknicken,
und das Ganze in der Natur.
Ich habe mir fest vorgenommen,
auf diesem Trip
beim Essen nicht heikel zu sein.
Ich habe wieder mal
nur ans Essen gedacht.
Das war dann aber bald
mein kleinstes Problem.
* Schwungvolle Rockmusik mit Dudel-
sack: "Epic Beersong" von Flannery *
Ein Kuhgatter.
Verdammt schön. Verdammt schön.
Siehst du die Schafe?
Ah ja.
Eine Wahnsinnslandschaft.
Die Schweiz, meine Frau, die Kinder,
alles ist schon weit weg.
So was mag ich.
Ich werde fast umgeweht.
Es ist schon sehr anders.
Hello.
- Hi.
Wir hatten 8 km geschafft,
als sich Böses ankündigte.
Ihr wisst ja noch:
die Wetterprognose.
Wo sind wir denn? Das ist nicht mehr
drauf. Nein, mach mich nicht krank!
Super! Regen im Anmarsch
und Monsieur Tageschef hat Mühe,
die Karte zu lesen.
Wir sind ... Nein. Wir sind
etwa hier und schauen zum Berg.
"Zum Berg" -
rundherum waren nur Berge, Burki!
Wir sind jetzt auf diesem Stück.
Es ist so weit,
die ersten Regentropfen fallen.
Nein! Jetzt heisst es
Zelt aufstellen,
jetzt heisst es kochen ...
Nein.
Oh, mir fallen
die Sachen unten raus.
Was? Nein, das ist
der Lüftungsschacht, Schatz.
Ui ui ui!
Nein!
Das ist, damit es reinziehen kann.
- Das habe ich jetzt auch gemerkt.
Du kannst dein Portemonnaie
in diese Tasche tun.
Hör doch auf!
Vielleicht muss man noch sagen,
dass Manu seine Kleider
vor der Reise nicht anprobiert hat.
Das wird sich noch rächen.
Do you have water?
Dieser schottische Jogger
hatte trotz Regen Durst.
Er trainierte für einen Marathon,
und wir wollten von ihm wissen,
wo man hier zelten kann.
I think
it's three miles more this way
and you can camp.
There's a campsite?
- No, there's just no barbed wire.
If it's barbed off like that,
you can't camp there.
And not near a water source.
Bye.
- Enjoy!
Verstanden haben wir nicht alles.
Irgendetwas mit Stacheldraht und
Bach und dort darf man nicht zelten.
Ah ja, ist doch egal.
Was muss man machen?
Zuerst so hinlegen, wie man es will?
Doch, doch, doch. Das hier, oder?
- Ja, das dünne ist das Aussenzelt.
Gut?
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir
das Zelt so schnell hinzimmern.
Zelt aufgestellt.
- Wir haben das Zelt aufgestellt.
* Surren *
Das wird schwierig, so verklebt.
Ich weiss.
Es muss einfach gleichmässig sein.
* Surren *
Musst du gleich von vorne reinhauen?
Ich brauche für meine Frisur,
die ja sehr lässig aussieht ...
Zwar zehn Jahre zu jung,
aber sehr lässig.
Ich habe extrem viel Aufwand.
Ich mache jeden Morgen
Salzwasser rein.
Dann föhnen, damit es hält.
Dann kommt etwas Gel rein,
und dann alle 3 Std. Spray.
Also weg damit!
Weisst du was? Ich bleibe
wegen des Gels mit denen hängen.
Er muss das Gel rauswaschen,
mit Wasser.
Gut, ich wasche mir
die Haare im Bach.
Shampoo, und zwar ist das
biologisch abbaubar - ich darf also.
Ah!
- Darf es etwas wärmer sein?
Einen Hauch wärmer.
Und Dai Sun
arbeitet nicht mehr bei Ihnen?
Nein, Sie hat
die zweite Filiale übernommen.
Sie ist etwas weiter flussabwärts.
Am Nacken auslaufend.
Oh, ja, das ist gut, weil ...
Hey, ich habe Kontaktlinsen drin,
du blöder Sack.
Oh, ja, jetzt geht es gut.
* Verspielte Musik *
Es ist nicht alles
ganz gleichmässig lang.
Was?
- Doch, doch.
Haben Sie noch andere ...
Das sieht geil aus.
- Ja, es sieht gut aus. Tipptopp.
Noch andere Körperstellen?
- Alles schon gemacht.
Danke, Burki.
Das ist deine.
- Danke.
* Regentropfen *
"Führen Sie die Pumpe
in die Brennstoffflasche ein
und befestigen Sie sie."
Mir ist das nicht geheuer.
- Das muss hier drauf.
Wir hatten keine Ahnung,
wie dieser Kocher funktioniert.
Das Einzige, was passieren kann,
ist, dass du Feuer fängst.
Ich fühle mich gut. Mir ist warm,
das ist die Hauptsache.
Wir kämpfen ein bisschen mit
der Nässe, weil wir kochen müssen.
Das ist ziemlich unangenehm.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Meine Geduld
wird auf die Probe gestellt.
Wir haben beide
noch nie so ein Teil bedient.
Schon wieder aus.
Irgendwas stimmt nicht.
Sobald ich es offen habe,
erstickt es.
So!
- Jetzt klappt es.
Verdammt!
Wir haben probiert und probiert.
Und hatten Hunger! Hunger!
So was macht mich rasend.
Bei so was habe ich keine Geduld.
- Schön warm.
Es schifft, ich habe kalte Finger.
Ich staune über deine Geduld.
- Ich habe megaviel Geduld.
Ich habe extrem ...
- Ich hätte es in den Bach geworfen.
Aber das weiss ich von mir.
Ich muss schnell schauen.
Lass es so!
- Nein.
Geht es zurück?
- Es geht weg.
Verdammt.
Nein!
Es dauerte lange,
bis wir merkten, wo das Problem lag.
Wir haben es 45 Min. lang versucht.
Der Kocher springt nicht richtig an.
Ich glaube, im Laden sagten sie,
das sei ein Benzinbrenner
und kein Brennspritbrenner.
Wir haben jetzt erst die Flasche
angeschaut, und es ist Brennsprit.
Ich bin angepisst.
- Das ist echt blöd.
Das ist wirklich blöd gelaufen.
So, dann ...
... holen wir ihren ...
Kocher.
- ... Kocher hierher.
Was auch nervt:
Ich bin bis auf die Unterhose nass.
Die Rettung war der Gaskocher
im Produktionsbus des Kameramanns.
Aber Manu hatte schon ein nächstes
Problem. Stichwort Kleidung.
Ich glaube, er versucht,
seine Regenhose anzuziehen.
* Lachen *
Auch hier
ein verdammt blöder Lapsus!
Was ist denn?
Ich hatte eine Regenhose anprobiert,
die man an der Seite öffnen kann,
damit man die Schuhe
nicht ausziehen muss.
Ich musste sie jetzt aber ausziehen.
Haben sie dir
die falsche Hose gegeben?
Die haben doch nicht
etwas Falsches eingepackt.
Es ist eine Hose,
die man nicht öffnen kann.
Es ist mir ein Rätsel warum.
Hm, das macht mich wütend.
Du hättest die Kleider nach dem Kauf
mal anprobieren müssen!
Fischer, lach nicht!
Burki, es tut mir leid, aber ich
finde es super. Ich finde es super.
Wir ...
- Nein, hey!
Komm, freuen wir uns,
zusammenzusitzen
und in dieser Pfütze
hier draussen zu kochen!
Es ist eine verdammte Pfütze!
Mach hier unten noch zu!
Du hast immer noch Luftlöcher.
Da sieht man,
wie outdoortauglich ich bin.
Ah, ich liebe dich dafür, Burki.
Ja, ja.
- Ist gut.
Mit dem Gaskocher gab es schnell ein
Risotto und v.a. wieder gute Laune.
Isch güet, hm?
- Isch geil.
Es ist hüeregüet.
Noch ein bisschen ...
Reicht das?
Es ist witzig: Wir haben uns
in den letzten 13 Jahren
in vielen Extremsituationen erlebt.
Aber so ein Fall, hier draussen
zu sitzen, es regnet, es windet,
man muss
einen Kocher in Gang bringen ...
Man hat Hunger und ist tropfnass.
- Das ist eine neue Situation.
Jetzt ist er ausgegangen.
Die ganze Nacht regnete es.
Das fanden nicht alle gleich lustig.
It was a fucking shit night.
Mir geht es blendend.
Ich bin einfach eine Frohnatur.
Nein, nein,
es ist anders als zu Hause.
Es hat uns einen Hering rausgehoben,
dadurch hat es reingeregnet und
der Schlafsack ist nass geworden.
Das hält einen vom Schlafen ab.
Ich glaube, ich habe
keine Minute wirklich geschlafen.
Heute Morgen habe ich mich
nicht getraut zu filmen.
Das hätte er nicht lustig gefunden.
Ich jammere nicht gerne rum,
aber es war Horror.
Für mich als nicht outdoor-approved
Mensch war es hardcore.
Die Umstände ...
Es fing schon beim Kochen an.
In der Nacht selber
habe ich keine Auge zugetan.
Ich dachte schon,
dass Manu so reagieren würde.
Manu hat nicht viel Geduld,
das weiss ich.
Aber das kann er ...
Im Alltag kommt es nicht oft vor,
wenn wir zusammen sind.
Aber wenn wir arbeiten,
habe ich ihn auch schon so erlebt.
Aber aus anderen Gründen.
Mir ist der Humor vergangen.
Ich habe eine gesunde Selbstironie,
ich kann lange über mich lachen,
aber mir ist der Humor
wirklich vergangen.
Jetzt geht es mir wieder besser,
ich hatte einen Tee.
Aber in der Nacht ...
Uh!
Ja, also ...
* Lachen *
* Der Regen prasselt aufs Zelt. *
Das ist übrigens der kleine Bach,
in dem ich die Haare gewaschen habe.
An diesem Tag
wäre nichts daraus geworden.
Was hast du mir noch übriggelassen?
- Wir konnten ja nicht kochen.
* Beschwingte Folk-Musik:
"If I Ever Leave This World Alive"
von Flogging Molly *
Endlich wieder unterwegs.
Meine Laune besserte sich
mit jedem Schritt.
Ich wusste, dass wir nach 3 km
etwas Wärmendes bekommen würden.
Wir besuchten
die erste Whisky-Destillerie
entlang des West Highland Way.
Das gehört ja zu Schottland.
* Beschwingte Folk-Musik *
Die Führung
dieses herzigen Fräuleins war super,
aber ehrlich gesagt, hat uns
das Degustieren mehr interessiert.
Und wir durften
unseren eigenen Whisky mischen.
Mein eigener.
So, dann habe ich meinen.
So geil.
Es sieht auch noch schön aus.
Huhu!
- Thank you very much.
That was very quick.
Grossartig.
Und so sind wir 2 Std. später
mit unserem eigenen Whisky
und einem Morgenschwips
weitergelatscht.
Destillerie - war gut.
10.30 Uhr, und wir hatten
noch kein Frühstück und nichts.
Einer der vermutlich
eher raren Momente
mit wärmenden Herbstsonnenstrahlen.
Während wir Schnaps schnüffelten,
besserte sich das Wetter.
Der Regen der letzten Nacht
war vergessen.
Für ein paar Minuten auf jeden Fall.
* Sanfte Musik: "Something
To Believe In" von King Creosote *
Wir haben zum ersten Mal
Sonne in Schottland,
das sind genau 3 cm der Zigarre.
Das heisst ... 10 Min. Sonne.
Not bad.
- Not bad.
Die Sonnenbrille kann man ausziehen.
An unserem zweiten Tag in Schottland
haben wir uns vorgenommen,
10 km zu laufen.
Laut Reiseführer gibt es nach
dieser Distanz einen Schlafplatz.
* Sanfte Musik *
Schon bald kommt ein ...
Es ist kein Campingplatz, aber es
gibt Bungalows. Relativ rudimentär.
Wir schauen es uns an, und sonst
gehen wir noch 2 km weiter nach ...
... "Dreimen" - Drymen,
man spricht es anders aus.
"Drimmen"?
- "Dream Men" oder so?
Genau.
Ha!
* Lachen *
Ein bisschen wie im Zelt.
Ich finde es ganz übel. Aber
schauen wir uns das andere mal an.
Du meinst, es gibt ein schöneres?
Wenn wir 2 km weiter die Möglichkeit
für ein Bett haben ...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen:
Das ist ein Holzdings, es ist eklig.
Schaum... Ja, also?
Wie weit müssten wir noch?
- 2 km.
Easy.
- Bist du dabei?
Basisdemokratisch haben wir uns
fürs Weiterlaufen entschieden.
Und es hat sich gelohnt - nicht nur
wegen des schönen Sonnenuntergangs.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das Dörfchen Drymen.
Hier haben wir uns von unterwegs
ein Bed and Breakfast organisiert.
Good evening.
- Oh, it's the BBC.
Yes, sorry.
- Fuck off!
Fuck off!
Diese Begrüssung mit einem
erwärmenden Fluchwort war hammer -
wie die Zimmer.
Ui, das ist schön!
Das ist schön!
Uah!
Nach einer Zeltnacht - ein Knaller!
Es war sensationell.
Ich bin einmal mehr
positiv überrascht
von der schottischen
Gastfreundschaft.
Die ganze Familie gehört dazu.
Er hat uns seine Frau
und seine Kinder vorgestellt.
Wir konnten heiss duschen,
das Zelt trocknen.
Er hat uns gleich gefragt,
ob wir nasse Sachen hätten.
Er hat unsere Schlafsäcke ...
- ... gleich vors Cheminee gelegt.
Er merkte gleich: "Hey,
wollt ihr nach dem engen Zelt
jetzt auch noch ein Bett teilen?
Nein. Ich hole eine Matratze."
Voll geil!
Nach der Basisdemokratie des Vortags
wollten wir wieder
klare Verhältnisse.
Wer weiter pinkeln kann,
nicht länger, sondern weiter ...
Distanz?
... der ist heute Tageschef.
Ich wäre ein knallharter Chef.
Dann macht die ganze Crew alles.
Ihr schleppt mich in einer Sänfte
über alle Hügel.
Ja, so kann ein Chef auch sein!
Logisch diskutiert man,
aber letztendlich darf er
den Stichentscheid geben.
Absolut.
(Mit französischem Akzent)
Durch den Dreck, wie?
Du hast hier ... Hör auf!
Du hast ein Füseli im Bart.
* Beschwingte Bluesmusik *
Jonny ...
Jonny hat seit gut 1 Std. Harndrang.
Und ich habe überhaupt
kein Bedürfnis zu pinkeln.
Jetzt zwingen sie mich,
Wasser zu trinken.
(Mit Ostschweizer Akzent) Wir gehen
jetzt da runter nach Wattwil
und essen im Bären etwas.
Oh nein!
Ja.
Ich bin dafür, dass wir
noch etwas essen vor dem Anstieg.
Zieh dich warm an,
sonst erkältest du dich.
Es ist geil,
es ist ein super Gefühl.
Ich möchte beim Mittagessen
eine Zigarre rauchen
und den Erfolg geniessen.
Du bist ein toller Kerl.
Ich glaube,
ich bin ein fairer Führer.
Der erste!
Du musst den Rucksack nicht
anziehen, wir essen etwas. - Ach so?
Es ist noch nicht klar,
ob Tageschef sein
ein Vorteil oder ein Nachteil ist.
Es kann auch ein Nachteil sein, wenn
man Entscheidungen treffen muss.
Mmh!
Es stimmt schon, dass wir oft,
wenn wir zusammen sind ...
... ich bin oft lustig mit dir.
Das stimmt. Und seien wir ehrlich:
Seit ich Kinder habe, sehen wir uns
einfach nicht mehr gleich oft.
Und wenn, dann sind wir
vielleicht auch erschöpft,
wenn wir vor der Show warten,
bis es losgeht.
Wir blödeln und
reissen weniger Witze als früher.
Deshalb schätze ich es
manchmal sehr,
wenn ich ausserhalb des Familien-
alltags Zeit mit ihm verbringe.
Nach all den Monaten, in denen wir
uns nicht gesehen haben, sowieso.
Wieder mal ein bisschen
Burkart-Fischer-Humor.
Um ein neues Comedyprogramm zu
schreiben, braucht es ganz viel ...
Was ist das Gegenteil
von Ernsthaftigkeit?
Gelassenheit, Ausgelassenheit,
Unbefangenheit,
um lustig zu sein
und Blödsinn zu machen.
Und es braucht eine grosse Portion
Kind im Manne.
Aber das in einen Rahmen zu bringen,
damit es ein Programm gibt,
das ist nicht mehr lustig.
Wenn wir proben
oder auswendig lernen -
letztes mal waren es 150 A4-Seiten.
Dann ist es nicht mehr lustig.
Dann heisst es auswendig lernen.
"Hey, hast du es gelernt?"
"Nein, du kannst es nicht. So können
wir nicht üben." Das ist Arbeit.
Es sind zwei verschiedene Dinge,
und zu meinen,
man könne etwas blödeln und habe
dann ein Programm, das reicht nicht.
Au, ich hab mir
auf die Zunge gebissen. Sorry.
* Stöhnen *
Kennt ihr das?
Ah, Fu-C-K!
Hör auf zu lachen, Fischer!
So viel zur Ernsthaftigkeit.
- Entschuldigung.
* Blues-Rock:
"I'm On My Way" von The Proclaimers *
Wir sind etwa 20 km
nördlich von Glasgow.
Und hier beginnen langsam
aber sicher die Highlands.
Pah, Highlands?
So hoch sind diese Berge hier nicht.
Wir steigen sicher auf den Gipfel.
Conic Hill, 358 m ü.M.
2'358 m ü.M.
Das Atmen macht schon Mühe.
Das ist ein Abstecher vom Weg,
hoch auf den Gipfel.
Deshalb haben wir
die Rucksäcke liegen gelassen.
Oh, ist das geil.
Yeah!
- Wow!
* Lachen *
Man kann sich fast
in den Wind legen.
Wunderschöne Aussicht, Loch Lomond.
Ja, wunderschön, aber ich habe mich
noch über etwas anderes gefreut.
Bis jetzt habe ich mich
darüber aufgeregt,
dass die Kameracrew ihre Rucksäcke
und das Zelt in den Bus legen kann
und wir alles mitschleppen müssen.
Jetzt sind unsere Rucksäcke unten
und die mussten alles schleppen.
* Hämisches Lachen *
Dieser See ist übrigens
die Grenze zu den Highlands.
Jetzt hat es für mich
richtig angefangen.
Wo ist Burkart? Der versteckt sich
wieder irgendwo in den Highlands.
Komme gleich.
Nein! Hey, verschwinde!
Hör auf!
- Du Sau.
Ich hatte gestern wohl zu viel
Knoblauchsauce an den Crevetten.
Dort unten am See liegt Balmaha,
ein kleiner Touristenort.
Unser Tagesziel.
Dort teilen wir uns ein Kämmerchen.
Grüezi!
Haben wir eine warme Dusche,
oder wie?
Verdammt heiss. Das ist das Geilste
nach einem solchen Tag.
Eine heisse Dusche und dann einen
Kaffee oder etwas trinken gehen -
das ist verdammt geil.
Dann lass ich dich jetzt
in intimity.
Super, danke.
* Gemütliche Musik:
"Dirty Old Town" von The Pogues *
* Baulärm *
(Laut) Ein neuer Tag.
Heute ist der Start
in die Highlands.
Natur pur.
- Wir freuen uns.
Deswegen sind wir hergereist,
dieses Natürliche,
wir sind ganz natürlich unterwegs.
Schön!
Das hat man in der Schweiz nicht.
Nirgends. Das ist Natur pur.
Ein paar Hundert Meter weiter
hat dann die Natur pur angefangen.
Aber wir hatten keine Augen dafür,
weil wir wussten,
dass wir 18 km würden laufen müssen.
Unser Tagesziel war eine kleine,
unbewartete Hütte irgendwo im Wald,
und wir wollten
vor Einbruch der Nacht dort sein.
Wir sind zackig unterwegs. Das ist
nicht Wandern, sondern Marschieren.
Wir haben die letzte Stunde
nicht geredet,
weil wir zackig unterwegs sind.
Ich hoffe, dass wir bis jetzt ...
Was waren das?
- 5 km?
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Es sind also noch ...
13 km.
- 13-14 km
Die Sonne kommt raus!
Ganz gute Bilder.
Das ist die längste Etappe, nicht?
Ich hoffe,
dass wir keine längere haben.
Das reicht eigentlich schon.
Unser Weg führte immer
am Loch Lomond entlang.
Traumhaft,
trotz der riesigen Distanz.
Auch am vierten Tag gab es noch
etwas zu klären: den Tageschef.
Ich hätte es gerne
ein zweites Mal gemacht.
Nach der ersten schottischen
Disziplin des Weitpinkelns
wären wir jetzt beim Schiferen.
Das ist auch Schiffen.
- Schifferen.
Weitschifferen.
Na ja, Tageschef ... Da ist
eine gewisse Nervosität vorhanden.
Bei mir auf jeden Fall.
Aber das wird schon gut.
Du fängst an, denn du hast
die Disziplin ausgewählt.
Gut, ich fange an.
- Und los.
Hör auf! Abstand, Abstand, bitte!
Ein, zwei.
- Zwei!
Okay.
Drei.
Das ist nicht gut für die Schulter.
- Ja, stimmt.
Nein! Zwei.
Sechs. Fünf oder Sechs.
- Fünf. Fünf.
Das ist der Letzte.
Zwei.
Ah!
So, jetzt wird wieder klar angesagt:
Wir gehen los, wir machen noch 4 km
und essen dann,
obwohl es schon 12 Uhr ist.
Ich hätte zwar Hunger.
- Das spielt keine Rolle.
Jetzt kann er mich quälen.
- Absolut.
Und die verdammte Sänfte,
blödes Team.
Ich will eine Sänfte.
Das habe ich gestern schon gesagt.
Eine Sänfte - das könnt ihr doch ...
Damit ich so ...
Du meinst, wir tragen dich
durch die Landschaft?
Ich habe etwas abgenommen.
Also gut. Nein, komm jetzt!
Weiter, weiter, weiter!
Mit Steinen geht es nicht gut, aber
Rucksack-Schiferen, das wäre was.
Wenn du es mit deinem machst, ja.
Jetzt will Monsieur Tageschef
auf seinem Stuhl dort hinten,
dass man ihn trägt.
Er wird gerade bedient,
der Tageschef auf seinem Stuhl.
* Punk-Rock:
"Nellie The Elephant" von Toy Dolls *
Mann, war das toll.
Ich werde getragen und Manu
schleppt meine Sachen hinterher.
So cool.
(Ironisch) Total cool.
Leider hat die Crew
nicht so lange durchgehalten,
aber es hat Vorteile, Chef zu sein.
Nein, nein, Streit gibt es sicher
keinen wegen des Tageschefs.
Ich frage ihn ab und zu schon,
ob es okay sei.
Und das Wasser tragen wir beide,
das ist klar.
Oh!
Schwierige Situationen
übernehme ich manchmal einfach so.
Ja, ja.
Wenn wir etwas Schwieriges
klären müssen, bin ich oft ...
Wenn es darum geht,
dass die Harmonie gebrochen wird,
habe ich oft nicht die Eier dazu,
die Faust auf den Tisch zu hauen.
Das macht er.
Und manchmal, aber nicht immer,
hast du genug davon.
Ja, denn dann
bin ich immer das Arschloch:
"Das sind zwar zwei lustige Komiker,
aber der Blonde ist ja mühsam!"
Wobei, oft ist es so,
dass es dich mehr stresst als mich.
Das ist dann eine blöde, kleine
Differenz bei der Empfindung,
die ihn dann aber fast dazu zwingt,
die Initiative zu ergreifen.
Aber ja, wir haben
schon einige Situationen erlebt.
Hier bis jetzt noch nicht.
- Nein, hier nicht.
Ich freue mich jetzt riesig
auf ein wärmendes Feuer.
Du kannst ihn mir geben.
- Jetzt musst du das Wasser nehmen.
Danke.
Das Kochwasser zu schleppen,
wurde auf den letzten Kilometern
bis zur Schutzhütte
noch anstrengend.
Und diese Baracke kam und kam nicht.
Es kann nicht mehr weit sein.
Durch den Wald abkürzen,
mag ich immer.
Bis jetzt lief es nicht schlecht.
Das sieht etwas spooky aus.
- Megaspooky.
Endlich!
Das ist ja der Hammer!
- Wo ist der Eingang?
Ah, dort oben.
- Das ist der Hammer.
Brennnesseln.
Es sieht aber schon
etwas schlimm aus.
Mal schauen, wie es innen aussieht.
- Ja, ja.
Rowchoish Bothy.
* Lachen *
Das ist doch geil.
Das ist doch de luxe, nicht?
Ich finde, es ist der Hammer.
- Ich bin megafroh.
Es ist wirklich der Hammer.
Logisch, es ist fast immer
unbewohnt, es ist dreckig,
aber das gehört auch
zu dieser Reise.
Absolut. Ich bin froh.
Der heutige Tag war etwas lang.
Ich bin etwas am Arsch.
Ich brauche Schokolade.
Willst du? Ich habe hier.
- Das wäre megalieb.
Ich muss echt ...
- Von zu Hause.
Ich habe am Schluss ... Für hierher
mussten wir alles packen ...
* Schlag *
Jetzt ist die Tür endlich mal zu.
... für diese zwei Tage,
Essen und alles.
Und gegen Ende
wurde es wirklich anstrengend.
Ich habe auch eine Blase
am rechten Fuss. Es war anstrengend.
Das war schwierig.
- Ja.
Furztrockenes findet man fast nicht.
- Nein.
Es ist auf jeden Fall härter,
als wir dachten.
Wir haben zwar gute Kleidung
und die Schuhe sind eingelaufen,
wir haben uns vorbereitet,
aber es ist eben doch etwas anderes,
2 Std. auf den Zugerberg zu laufen
mit einem 6 kg schweren Rucksäckchen
und zu meinen, man sei vorbereitet,
als hier 20 km zu latschen
mit allem Möglichen auf dem Rücken.
Nach unserem Debakel am ersten Abend
wollten wir es noch mal wissen -
mit dem Kocher.
Ist es Benzin?
Diesel, aber ja ...
Fischer, super Vorbild mit dem
Stumpen an der Benzinflasche!
Zigarre! Zigarre, Manu!
Gleich läuft es über.
Zumachen.
Und anzünden.
Nehmen wir die Sachen weg.
Achtung, Feuer... Wie heisst das?
Voll easy.
- Das wärmt auch gleich.
Und ich kann die Zigarre
noch mal anzünden.
Die Nasenspitze wärmen.
Ja, definitiv.
Warte mal,
wie haben wir das gemacht?
Voila!
Muss man noch mal pumpen?
Ja, es muss Druck
auf der Flasche sein.
Kann ich ihn draufstellen?
- Ja!
Ja, das ist doch easy.
Das ganze Zeug ist doch easy.
Es gibt etwas Warmes zu essen.
Mmh!
Ganz guten Appetit!
Ah, war diese Pasta fein!
Fast so gut wie
in meinem heiss geliebten Italien.
Ich sage nichts mehr.
Und endlich, nach vier Tagen
in Schottland - ein Lagerfeuer!
Einen Drittel des Weges nach
Fort William hatten wir geschafft.
Zeit für unseren eigenen Whisky.
Das kann aber rein, das ist Karton.
Ist das schön!
Mich hat wirklich beeindruckt,
wie Jonny Ruhe bewahrt hat
in dieser ersten schwierigen Nacht.
Bzw. beim Kochen.
Unterwegs hatten wir
ein paar schöne Gespräche,
was wir in diesem Jahr erlebt haben,
was jeder privat so gemacht hat.
Ich glaube eher, so wie wir uns
kennen, das hat sich alles vertieft.
Oder bestätigt.
Ich habe nicht
etwas Meganeues erfahren,
aber es hat megaviel bestätigt -
wie wir uns kennen und wie
unsere Freundschaft funktioniert.
Waldbrandgefahr
besteht hier wohl nicht gross.
Ich glaube, das gab es
in Schottland noch nie.
Verdammt schön!
* Sanfte Musik *
In der nächsten Folge
schiessen wir scharf ...
... entdecken
das Nationalgericht ...
... und ziehen einen Brocken
aus dem Wasser.
Dass ich das
an meinem Geburtstag erleben darf.
Wir hausen wie Lords ...
... und verwandeln uns
langsam in Schotten.
Das und noch viel mehr
in der nächsten Folge von
"SRF bi de Lüt - Durch dick ...
... und dünn".